Monday was Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. day,
and, as is the case with almost everything
lately, virtually everyone on social media
seemed to parse out MLK's words for whatever
narrative they're currently trying to push
in our modern times.
I saw articles on how MLK was the first environmentalist,
how he was an ardent feminist, a communist,
a socialist and much more.
The one quote I tweeted of his is perhaps
his most famous: "I have a dream that my four
little children will one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the color
of their skin, but by the content of their
character."
I believe this quote to be as relevant now
as it was in the early 1960's, but for a whole
other set of reasons.
In the 60's, MLK was fighting for equality
under the law and equality of opportunity,
two things we should all believe in.
Today, those who judge people by the color
of their skin and not the content of their
character are fighting not for equality, but
for special treatment of some at the exclusion
of others.
This misguided principle - thinking you should
treat someone differently because of their
skin color, or thinking someone should believe
what you think they should believe because
of their skin color, or any other immutable
characteristic - is the essence of prejudice
which means to prejudge.
This is the complete reverse of what MLK stood
for, and sadly, this way of thinking has infected
the modern Left almost wholly.
This is why like myself, so many of you find
yourselves on the outside of a political bubble
you were once safely a part of.
For this Direct Message though, I don't want
to focus on the flaws of identity politics.
Instead, I want to focus on one of the other
topics I just mentioned...
socialism.
And for the purposes of this message, I want
to put aside whether MLK was a capitalist
or a communist or a socialist or a hybrid
of any of these.
What I want to discuss is some of the reaction
around the word socialism itself.
The amount of people I see talking about socialism
positively is actually staggering.
A tweet I sent out saying socialism isn’t
cool even got me into a little exchange on
Twitter with the official verified Socialist
Party, who explained to me that socialism
has never actually been tried which is why
we don't know if it will work yet.
Perhaps they should tell that to the people
of Venezuala right now, who are fighting for
food and basic services as they watch their
socialist system collapse on top of them.
The ideas of socialism, that the means of
production, distribution and labor should
be owned, controlled and regulated by the
community as a whole are the worst sort of
collectivist ideas which exist.
The very implication that the group knows
what is good for the individual, that we exist
to do things for the greater good, is totally
antithetical to the purpose of being human.
It's your job to find value in your work,
to strive for more than you have, to bring
good to yourself and the people around you
and to live as a free person as you see fit.
The very idea that you should set aside your
individuality for the community as a whole,
which virtually always turns into an intolerant
hostile mob, is exactly why so many have died
in socialist regimes.
Despite the obvious failures of socialism,
socialists have no problem using the freedoms
of capitalism against itself.
This is perhaps the most perverse part of
the socialist world view.
Much like Islamism, socialism wants to use
our freedoms against us until it attains complete
power.
For example, they use the tools of Twitter
and Facebook, companies created through the
ingenuity of individuals and the freedom of
capitalism, to attack the very system they
live in.
By the way, I'm all for them being able to
do this even if I don't like what they're
doing.
That's the tricky part of freedom, it even
applies to people and ideas you don't like.
Just think for a moment if we had a socialist
government in charge...how do you think it
would be going for free expression and free
speech?
How tolerant would they be of all the people
they label nazis and bigots?
Whatever you may think of Trump and the evil
capitalists, are they the ones coming for
anyone's speech?
Are reporters being put in jail?
Actually, President Obama used the espionage
act to put a record number of reporters in
jail, and as for as I know, Trump, who dislikes
the press to put it mildly, hasn't put anyone
in prison for the crime of journalism.
Fortunately I see a major rising tide in America
based on liberty, freedom and individual choice.
Note how those words themselves are somehow
thought of as evil in the socialist lexicon.
Liberty, freedom, and individual choice must
all be sacrificed for the greater good...though
what they're not telling you is that the greater
good is usually for the tiny minority in the
elite protected class.
Their ideas have never worked and will never
work because a system built on stripping our
humanity is in direct conflict with being
a human.
I've said it before and I'll say it again,
this perfect system which they want to create
can never be perfect because we humans, as
flawed as we are, are part of it.
Imperfect beings can't create a perfect system,
but what we can create is a system that always
does it's best to further the advancement
of human freedom.
For all it's flaws, this is what capitalism
is, which is why if you're watching this from
a capitalist society you should consider yourself
one of the lucky ones.
Of course in America politicians don't call
themselves outright socialists, they say "Democratic
socialists."
This is Bernie's mantra as he calls for a
revolution of every kind, be it political,
social or environmental.
What Bernie forgets, or intentionally obfuscates,
is that the Democratic part of this will of
course be tossed away as socialism takes root.
It's also why there's no doubt in my mind
that eventually the social justice movement
will turn on Bernie himself.
Democracy is the enemy of socialism and Bernie
is trying to have it both ways.
There's also a reason that the social justice
movement has such a socialist strain within
in.
Both of these movements, based on frowning
on achievement and accomplishment, and a resentment
of those who break the mold, need people to
be oppressed...or at least believe they're
oppressed, to survive.
Creativity, free thought, and the pursuit
of your own happiness is the antidote to both
social justice and socialism.
It's either that or a life of bitterness,
resentment, and jealousy, which in my view
is less socialism and more just anti-social.